en ville vivons nous vraiment
mais voilà si l'anti vivons tous
six mois
à
mais vous écrire l'histoire
la jeune fille s'appelle sharon elle ne
sait pas où aller elle ne sait pas ce
qu'elle fait elle pense qu'elle devait
venir passer un casting à paris
donc ils sont venus dans la région
parisienne on leur a dit un casting a
pas si elle ne s'est pas du tout qu'il y
avait un nez sur le plateau ne sais pas
quelle est dans les locaux ne touche pas
à mon poste
on lui a mis un casque un millionnaire
bandeau je vais demander le calme le
plus total
on va la faire rentrer sur le plateau on
va lui enlever le bandeau et je crois
que vianney a préparé une petite chanson
pour elle qu'elle pense qu'il va faire
un casting les yeux bandés
non après on lui a dit on lui a dit
voilà il ne vous inquiétez pas ne le
fait pas ça pour lui ai dit voilà on
peut pas dire on va te faire une
surprise c'est pas pourquoi elle est là
ok vianney vous voulez prendre la
guitare paix vianney alors elle ne sait
pas pourquoi elle vient donc silence
total je vais chercher la personne a pas
demain
il ya mis de la musique donc elle
n'entend rien que je propose d'abord
enlever ça entendez ça va pour
connaissez ma moi non s'appeler sharon
ça va tu reconnais pas du tout ma voix
non pas du tout
[Rires]
les force à rolle tu doutait pas du tout
on me dit souvent tu as dit que tu étais
venu faire quoi comme robert de niro
bordeaux tout ça on te dit que tu allais
faire quoi un casting et que j'allais
chanter avec les yeux bandés avec clic à
laquelle a ajouté que les yeux bandés
avec quelqu'un et ouais c'est un nouveau
concept avec the voice mais en fait
c'est les gars qui voient pas la vie on
va pas le principe en fait c'est en fait
tu dois pas voir le jury est un des plus
fins jury t'enlève le dos entre
mécontentement sharon ont mis là je
crois qu'il a une surprise pour toi
vianney le nouvel album
vianney on t'aime fort moshiri vraiment
et tu continues tu leur dis merci axelle
laffont hypersensible attention les deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nature connais pas trop mais ça va pas
tarder
m
on sera débit veut d'amour attend ce
des filles pourtant
[Musique]
avant
décrire
le jour
suivant mais voulant de ville en ville
vivons nous vraiment
mais relancé en vivons nous vraiment
mais voilà si l'anti vivons tous les
mois
mais volant de ville en ville vivons
nous nous aimons
[Musique]
mais chez les messieurs les bravos saron
moi bon match et rim c'est sûr que c'est
une bonne surprise ou pas peut-être
c'est une bonne surprise une petite
était fan absolu de yannick restera un
souvenir tu va le garder toute ta vie
dans ta tournée car si ces résultats un
amour vous bien et c'est moi qui les
remercie yade et j'ai perdu 4
[Applaudissements]